the percent of adults who smoke recorded
every year every few years since 1967
suggests a negative linear association
with no outliers
on average the percent drops by 0.5
points each year which of the following
plots suits the above description
so let's see this looks like a negative
linear correlation or lit association as
the years go by you have a smaller
percent of smokers this one does two as
years go by you have the number of
smokers go down and down
this one
down here also looks like that although
it's not as smooth if you were to fit a
line here it looks like you have a few
outliers while this is a positive
correlation so we can definitely rule
out graph four now the other thing that
they told out they told us is that there
are no outliers suggest a negative
linear association with no outliers if
you were to try to fit a line to graph
three you could fit a line pretty
reasonably that would go someplace like
that but it would have this outlier it
would have this outlier right over here
it looks like it's 12 or 13 years it
looks about 13 years after
1967 so that would be
1980 looks like an outlier there but
they said it doesn't have any outliers
so we would rule out graph number three
and so we're we have to pick between
graph one and graph two and so the other
the other hint they give us or piece of
data they give us is that the percent
drops by 0.5
each year 0.5 percent each year
so here what's happening as 10 years go
by let's see as we go from let's start
with let's see in 1967 where it looks
like we're about 55 percent
and then 10 years go by
we are roughly at around 45
a little under 45
so we dropped 10 percent in 10 years
that seems to be how much this is
dropping about roughly 10 percent in 10
years another 10 years go by we go from
45 or a little more than 10 in 10 years
and so that would mean that we're
dropping on average more than one
percentage point per year that seems
more than what's going on here now let's
look over here
over here we're starting it looks like
around 42 percent and then after 10
years it looks like we're at like
37 percent so it looked like we it looks
like we've dropped about five percent in
ten years which is consistent with this
if you drop five percent in ten years
that means you drop half a percent per
year so we'll go with graph two